Speaker 1: So now that we're getting into really
the meat of the 2022 midterm elections, we've had
some primaries, we have a bunch of other primaries
coming up. We are getting into the farcical
cringe stage of many of these candidacies. And
we're going to look at a couple of the different
candidates in ads today. We're going to start with
Mehmet Oz. Mehmet Oz is running for Senate. He's
running in the Republican primary in Pennsylvania.
He's been endorsed by Trump. But as we saw
yesterday in some clips from the weekend's rally,
many Trumpists aren't thrilled with Mehmet Oz.
And one of the reasons that they're not thrilled
with Mehmet Oz is that really he has a decade plus
of saying stuff about politics that aligns more
with the Democratic than the Republican Party.
I think Mehmet Oz is completely unqualified.
He's done quack doctor stuff on TV for years.
He's dishonest, all these different things.
But it is also true that at least some of his
positions historically have lined up more with the
Democratic Party than the Republican Party. This
includes his views on guns. Early in the pandemic,
he was more aligned with the pro-science side,
which was the more left leaning side. Let's be
frank. And he's recently had to change a lot
of these positions, and he now has completely,
it almost seems, satirical ad where he's firing
guns. And the thing about this is the first
level of cringe would be someone running and
in a serious manner. Having these views about guns
and doing these types of videos where they're out
on the range, firing at clay pigeons and this
type of thing. The second layer of cringe is
what Oz is doing, which is it doesn't even seem
like it's genuine. He's pandering with this stuff,
even though it doesn't align with the Mehmet Oz
that we've known for a decade. So we're going
to look at the ad. And if you're not watching, if
you're just listening, I will mention that there
is a particular shot where it sort of looks like
Oz is shooting and hitting a clay pigeon. These
are like these discs that are thrown into the air.
But if you look at how it's cut, it's very obvious
that they filmed him firing the weapon and then
later filmed the clay pigeon exploding. And it's
pretty damn obvious that Oz didn't hit the clay
pigeon. Not that it matters. It's all absurd. So
let's look at the ad and then we'll talk about it.
Speaker 2: My father taught me how to handle my
first gun. I taught my son Oliver, how to do
the same. I've been shooting, hunting my whole
life. So when people say I won't support guns,
they're dead wrong. But. Other conservatives
know that I'm strong on the Second Amendment.
Ted Nugent. Rick Perry. President Trump. But
our Second Amendment is not just about hunting.
It's about our constitutional right to protect
ourselves from intruders or an overly intrusive
government. So as your next U.S. Senator,
I will fight for our constitutional rights. Yeah.
Speaker 1: We need the guns to protect ourselves
from an overly intrusive government. Sort of like
one that says there's no right to an abortion and
states can ban it. Listen, we have a Second
Amendment. We have a Second Amendment period.
Right. I support mandatory gun training,
licensing, relicensing mandatory insurance,
eliminating the so-called gun show or boyfriend
loophole or whatever they're calling it these
days. You got to have a background check for every
transaction. All we have a Second Amendment and I
support all of that stuff. Oz has had a somewhat
similar view to that for most of his public record
until recently, and now it's very clear that he'll
say whatever the hell he has to in order to try to
win a Republican primary. And this is very similar
to the Trump abortion thing. Oz pushed gun safety
regulations most of his public life. He wrote OP
Ed's. He said, We need to we need gun control.
We need to, quote, stop gun violence. We need
to treat shootings as a public health emergency,
which I agree with. And then now all of a
sudden, he's having to backtrack and find
and stake out this new position. Remember,
Donald Trump was pro-choice his entire life.
He was 68 years old and he had been pro-choice
his entire public life. Up until that point,
he had no shot at winning the Democratic
presidential nomination in 2016. So he ran as
a Republican and he had to stake out a position on
abortion that would be palatable to Republicans.
So Trump came up with this awakening that he
had. He knew and he knew. People around him knew.
You need a story. You need an explanation
as to why you were pro-choice for 68 years
and now you are suddenly anti-choice. And Trump
story paraphrased was he met a kid once? I don't
remember if the kid was 12 or 16 at the time.
And the kid's mother said to Trump, you know, I
thought about getting an abortion. And I decided
not to. And the awakening Trump had was, Wow,
I like this kid. This is a good kid. Abortion is
bad. And now I'm against abortion for all these
religious, all these different reasons that
are completely unbelievable. This is kind of
a similar thing, which is Ozz now has to stake out
this pro wildly pro-gun position. Now, how is the
is this helping him? How is the primary and how
how is the race going? So on the Republican side.
Oz does appear to be winning, although it's
it's within the margin of error. On average,
Oz is ahead of the second place candidate
McCormick by two and a half and then ahead of the
third place candidate Barnett by four points. Now
it's almost certain that if McCormick or Barnett
bowed out, the other one would consolidate a
bunch of that support and might might be able to
defeat Oz. But that's the way it's looking right
now. Oz with a slight lead. And then over on the
Democratic side, John Fetterman, who is my choice,
although his debate performance wasn't very good,
Fetterman is my choice in Pennsylvania. He
has opened up on an average a 31 point lead
over the second place contender, Conor LAMB.
So it's almost certainly going to be Fetterman
against whoever wins the Republican
primary. So that's what's going on there.
We'll continue to watch it. And Dr. Oz used to do
surgeries on people. That's that's quite a thing